and your own words describe the phasic
and like your characters and and their
change
um yeah so yeah the show is very
expensive like you start out the series
realizing that these two characters have
not only divorced but in some kind of
horrible way and then the show kind of
flashes back in time and jumps around in
time and you see not only like how they
met but how they flourished as a couple
but you also start to see kind of like
the cracks in the relationship and you
as an audience I mean like to me what's
really interesting about it is like
knowing how they wind up makes all of
the good stuff seem uh that much more
tragic knowing that this is a doomed
marriage that you're watching flourish
uh makes it that much more tragic
because you like seeing them together
they seem to like solve something for
each other for my character Toby he
wants like stability he wants somebody
who doesn't like apologize for herself
somebody who is
um you know self-sufficient and who
seems like the most stable person can be
a stable mother and that's what he sees
in Rachel and for her she sees and Toby
somebody who can you know fill a gap of
a lost family and and stability and
structure and grounding and yet you know
that their marriage is doomed so what's
fascinating is that you're taking a very
like 360 degree look at this you know
doomed but uh hopeful at one point
relationship
yeah and I think it you know they're
both very much
immersed in the process of separating
um you know so they they're freshly
divorced and they're still reeling right
and and what I loved about the book and
now the interpretation of the book but
you know we hear the the the account
mostly through Toby's perspective
um and then we kind of forget that we're
getting a one-sided account and it's
only at the very end when we realize the
the you know Rachel who has been pretty
you know uh villainized throughout uh
has has her her own take on it which is
you know actually not all that
dissimilar and I mean the actual uh
facts are aligned but the uh the
experience of it is is very is almost
flipped right so um and playing with
perspectives is a is a wonderful trick
of the story that Taffy crafted really
beautifully the writer
I know I felt like he was definitely
watching you guys and just definitely
being on like Rachel's side or being on
Toby's side it's definitely you switch
through that and also a major theme of
the um the show was just like belonging
of Youth and you guys were both
celebrities in your youth obviously
there you be in my so-called life and
Jesse being The Social Network what do
you guys miss most about that time
my knees used to work better but my dad
had warned me when I was very young that
I'm gonna have bad knees because it's
inherited and so in some ways I was
looking forward to it because it meant
you know I was on the right path and I'm
in some ways like a you know an
ambassador for the family and the
Eisenberg name but um in other ways it's
hard to sit cross-legged and then get up
after about 30 seconds
um I missed nothing from my youth
because when I was a child I just wanted
to be an adult and I know you hear
people say that and then they say the
second part which is and now I want to
be a child but I don't feel that way at
all I hated it I hated being young I
hated having no control over my life and
having to hang out with people my own
age yeah and I'm so much happier now and
I just can't wait until I'm even older
I feel the same way yes I was um always
uh out of step with my um my my formal
technical age so it's a relief to be a
slightly more appropriate yeah yeah
you'd be much more appropriate about 30
years
I've got a raging grandma with him so
yeah okay amazing that's all the time we
have you guys okay thank you thank you
we'll close it with rage and Grandpa
yeah exactly